aujourd'hui on a fait livrer au
connecteur une boîte de 6 e périgny avec
dedans 3 au frais et trois aux durs
numérotée chacun votre tour je vais vous
poser des questions sur l'actu télé avec
quatre oppositions si vous répondez bien
vous désigner une personne qui va devoir
se casser un oeuf sur la tête si vous
répondez mal c'est pour votre pomme
ciboure et voilà je pense que je vois
pas de questions michel que j'aime
énormément qui joue avec nous et qui
joue toujours le jeu bravo mme aux gens
me croisent les chéris question on va
démarrer par benjamin castaldi castaldi
castaldi en collant taille dans koh
lanta vendredi qu'a dit moussa sur avaaz
un autre candidat
c'est un poissard il a des pieds on
dirait une calzone il sert à rien ou
casse toi pauvre con
il sert à rien il sert à rien vous êtes
sur wii sur jean-michel on ne confie
c'est parti
[Musique]
mach est désolé c'était le moins bon
deux ânes à versols avant suis déçu
[Musique]
wedge oppose ceux qui n'ont pas cette
habitude de manger juste un petit mot
sur hamad
il est actuellement avec le médecin qui
est en train de l'observer à bad boy
sérail en fait si perte ou vertige c'est
un truc que j'aurais pu courir dans koh
lanta il servir tout ça c'est moussa qui
dit ça bonne réponse de benjamin
castaldi alors pour ceux qui n'ont pas
vu koh lanta c'était vendredi soir ça a
cartonné 1 43 4 % des moins de 50 ans et
aux devant koh lanta et c'est vrai que
c'est un nouveau record pour cette
saison pour koh lanta qui fait du bien
me voilà qu'à saison soit bonne ou pas
bonne
franchement tout le monde et devant la
télé c'est un programme familial on a
envie de regarder et puis on va pas se
mentir sur les autres chaînes y avait
rien du tout franchement vendredi soir
c'était un drame humain vendredi soir ça
veut dire que vous voulez des prix mais
tu te mettais sur d'autres émissions que
koh lanta quatuor a rigolé tu prenais un
truc tu prenais un an baissant ul et tu
prenais un pic à glace tu te le foot et
dont lui alors bon ceux qui n'ont pas
suivi des missions vous explique tout ça
en vidéo regardez vendredi se déroulait
le septième épisode de la nouvelle
saison de koh lanta et le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que l'ambiance était
tendue à que le premier conseil de la
réunification et cette semaine qu'on se
le dise et l ea macho le seul candidat
qui dans l'histoire de koh lanta a
réussi à prendre de kilos et est au
coeur de toutes les attentions un
candidat dont le talent n'est pas de se
faire des amis à bad boy sert à rien en
fait s'il perd tout ça n'est pas non
plus l'équilibré
ni la santé juste un petit mot sur hamad
il est actuellement avec le médecin est
malheureusement son talent n'est pas non
plus le tir à l'arc
dommage car cette semaine l'épreuve de
confort se jouer justement au tir à
l'arc
regardez ce que je vais donner à celui
ou à celle qui l'emportent
c'est finalement theora qui remporte
l'épreuve au fil d'une finale tendue
contre claude au nom
la victoire pour l'épreuve d'immunité
c'est le parcours du combattant que
jessica remportent l'épreuve des femmes
claude celle des hommes
deux candidats qui ont dû se départager
autour d'un petit buffet gourmand
croquant j'ai peint et c'est finalement
claude qui remporte le totem d'immunité
une semaine où alexandra avait toujours
plus le sommes moi c'est une nouveauté
sam le retrait sable sais pas du tout si
et puis sa stratégie qui change dans les
moments plus je n'ai pas du tout aimé ce
que tu m'as fait lors de l'épreuve de
confort d'hier je suis fatigué du
l'épreuve est énervé quant à saab lui a
encore une fois montré qu'il était
totalement fan de théo à des gens comme
toi et si jusqu'au bout amadora tenter
de gratter une alliance de tous je suis
fini
c'est finalement lui qui quittera
l'aventuré la bad les aventuriers de la
tribu réunifiée ont décidé de vous
éliminer et leur sentence est
irrévocable
un départ auquel 6 millions 800 mille
téléspectateurs auront assisté vendredi
soir
[Musique]
avec koh lanta maintenant je vous le dis
c'est que koh lanta étant donné qu'ils
ont énormément réduit koh lanta c'est à
dire que maintenant le résumé de
l'épisode dure plus longtemps que
l'épisode en lui-même
j'ai pas de remarquer alors mais c'est
vrai c'est un truc de fou ça veut dire
qu'ils j'espère que vous avez remarqué
ça déchire et alors on adore mais le
résumé ils te disent oui il a été
truquée même là ce qu'on avait un
terreau la ceinture plus autant que
l'émission c'est devenu un truc de fou
pour serge lama oui oui mathieu et la
semaine prochaine il va encore diffusé
un épisode coupé en deux parce qu'en
fait ils veulent que la finale soit en
direct ah ouais d'accord j'espère mais
voilà c'est la semaine prochaine ce sera
encore très court c'est quand même se
vendre y jean-michel norbit c'est bien
et c'est vrai que quand période de
confinement voir et les émissions et
jenson extérieur comme ça à l'air libre
sur une plage ça fait vraiment du bien
quant à hama bien sûr dans les cinq
premières minutes leur et cinq premières
minutes de kolontar co se jeter à l'eau
il sait pas nager
sa femme s'est fait écrit je devais
dégager le pauvre est le pauvre il ya sa
main franchement qui est digne des héros
1 et a alors moussa mais ça c'est
fantastique ça mais les fantastiques
justement lors de l'épreuve de confort
et un candidat cabriès et ça c'était une
épreuve de tir à l'arc et le gars il a
été quasiment à chaque fois le meilleur
de l'épreuve rappeler cette histoire là
un voilà etc et voilà on tire comme ça
et après on casse une flèche ça j'adore
sa découverte des confiné on va le
refaire savais que je me suis entraîné
au tir à bout ce n'est qu'un gros et je
le dis aux téléspectateurs je vous jure
que c'est vrai j'avais pour projet de
m'inscrire aux jeux olympiques pour la
tunisie
en tir à l'arc je vous jure que c'est
vrai c'est pas du tout une vanne jean
michel est ce que c'est vraiment ne joue
pas la bce ben moi je lui c'est chez
vous et on a fait du tir à l'arc mais la
cible c'était mes fesses vous rappelle
waié coup c est bon en tout cas je vous
ai montré que les ai pas loupé c'est
parti prenez votre
placez votre flèche
armée
[Applaudissements]
c'est la plus proche du centre c'est la
flèche noire
la flèche de sam
tiens
[Musique]
la meilleure flèche incontestablement
c'est celle ci c'est la flèche sommes
pour la première fois une flèche et
d'arriver en plein centre c'est une
nouvelle fois la flèche noire troisième
victoire pour ça
il y a deux flèches qui sont très
proches l'une de l'autre mais celle qui
est la plus près du sang s'est une
nouvelle fois la flèche noire pour la
quatrième fois sam
vous êtes le meilleur
[Musique]
ouais il est fort ce sam sam il a des
petits airs je passe vous rappelez de
billy crawford clip entre chaque ennemi
au chac amy winehouse tony wang lin et
au moins il paraît que c'est devenu une
très grande star aux philippines il est
présentateur aux philippines maintenant
billy crawford
c'est une petite amie delory à l'époque
ouais parce que c'est un bon mois et a
quant à elle a écrit la chanson moi je
préfère rester tout seul c'est pour lui
dire qu'elle voulait plus de lui
j'ai tout suivi et un moment déjà dit
c'est ce que j'aimerais que tu sois ma
meilleure amie
toutefois tout coup enfin tu tapes
herbiers peau nue je serai toujours là
voilà un petit peu de laurine ne fait
jamais de mal oui j'adore oui j'adore
oui oui je sais on peut remarquer quand
on est en couple à confinement il ya des
dizaines de mercenaires intelligent et 6
millions ça reste un score très bon mais
moi je m'attendais honnêtement que des
chaînes comme tf1 par exemple france 2
et m6 fait des très très gros scores les
seconds sont pas gigantesques cyril
honnêtement non mais c'est pas mal c'est
vrai mais en parts de marché c'est
permis c'est la faune est d'accord voilà
c'est ce que je vais vous dire jean
michel maire non je jugerai agira sam
évidemment il est beau mais moi il a un
côté un peu énervant c'est fait tout le
monde essaie trop préparé il a il a
appris à faire d'une chose
l'acteur de minutes il acquiert un
radeau dans son jardin il a appris à
faire du tir à l'arc avant c'est un peu
trop compétiteur il veut trop bouffé
tout le monde sa mère va alors mais moi
oui tu vas dire alors moi j'allais dire
un truc
et franchement je me suis dit ça mais il
a complètement raison moi demain je sais
que je vais koh lanta mais les chéris je
vous dire la vérité toute la journée de
8 heures du matin à 10h je fais du tir à
l'arc tous les jours de 10h à 12h je
vais nager et je leur mets des dégelées
je vais ouvrir ta d'un de 12h à 14h jeu
construire ados de 14 heures à 16 heures
j'essaie de faire du feu avec un morceau
de chaussures et est un caillou non mais
je vous dis mais rien n'est exclu
la raison mais je vous dise moi si je
dommage devait faire koh lanta je dors
sur des poteaux tenir trois ans dort sur
un poteau et je regarde ce que ça donne
mais c'est normal
celui qui est complètement fois celui
qui me fait beaucoup rire c'est hamad
c'est le seul gars le seul aventurier
mine de rien c'est pas dejong koh lanta
y sait pas nager
c 'est c'est exceptionnel c'est comme
son frère tu vas faire top chef
tu sais pas faire cuire à 9 non mais
c'est cet été je moi je suis fan de ce
mec
mine de rien c'est exceptionnel alors à
rades il est en sursis depuis un petit
moment et cette fois il n'a pas pu
échapper à l'élimination
voilà ahmad je pense que la première
chose qu'il fait en rentrant et la
première chose qu'il a dû faire parce
qu'il a dû rentrer il doit être en
confinement aussi amat d'ailleurs on
embrasse que moi il me fait et fait
énormément rire là à mon avis d qui va
sortir il va s'inscrire à des cours de
natation c'est sûr et cherche à regarder
ahmad prenez votre sac aller récupérer
votre flambeau et venez me rejoindre
[Musique]
ahmad les aventuriers des tribus
auraient initié ont décidé de vous
éliminer et leur sentence est
irrévocable
ouais je suis déçu parce que je vais pas
plus loin vu à je suis pas triste j'en
veux à personne j'ai pas de rancune et
que le meilleur gagne sincèrement d'un
match j'ai cru comprendre que tu avais
les dents longues
bien je te propose de rentrer chez toi
que les ferrari mais il ya quelqu'un qui
vous dit hamada c'est un art halak lui
dit qu'elle d'arc à ahmad je suis morte
à chaque fois c'est vrai qu'à mal à
m'accepter le maillon faible de cette
saison hamad
vous êtes le maillon faible au revoir
mais moi moi je trouve qu'il a il est
d'ailleurs il est très beau gosse déjà
hamad et 2 il a il a du cran quand même
arrivé à koh lanta tu sais pas nager
tu sais pas tirer à l'arc tu sais pas
faire du feu c'est quand même beaucoup
quoi c'est comme si tu venais à touche
pas à mon poste et tu connaissais rien à
la télé bah on a l'exemple et jean
michel maire
voilà merci on se prépare un peu séché
d'accord mais ça reste avant tout une
aventure humaine c'est sale et j'oserais
de la survie moi je vous dirai at il y
en a mais ils de rien je sais pas pour
vous mais si vous allez à koh lanta ce
serait pour gagner arrêtez oui
franchement alors sur koh-lanta c'est
pour gagner je suis désolé gens me
gilles verdez mais insurgés pas du tout
d'accord avec jean michel sam
c'est le vrai aventurier de la trempe
des plus grands il a appelé à faire le
saut il à faire ça c'est génial et byron
ne va pas gagner j'en ai déjà perdu
il était uniquement stratège de marché
matthieu delormeau évidemment que c'est
ridicule parce que les premières années
il y avait tony vous souvenez de tous
ces gens là question connaissez mal les
missions et le but était justement n'ont
pas gagné 5000 euros même temmar
l'argent c'était de voilà c'était
marrant et c'était de se surpasser avec
ses propres compétences aujourd'hui on a
des mecs c'est rambo sa vie peut tout
faire il peut tuer à tuer un ours à
mains nues ça n'a plus aucun intérêt de
regarder l'émission maintenance ou font
des pros qui sont golay et ce sont des
pros de la devanture entre eux moi
j'adorais lettonie les mecs qui savait
pas nager qui s'engueulent acteurs
investissent et ayari gg y avait jugé
que ces passagers qui est exceptionnel
ne repasse un jour l'extrait de gg dans
tpm et s'embrassent et j'ai dit je vais
le repas c'est dommage encore passer
devant alors oui il ya eu il ya une
épreuve culte de koh lanta vendredi
c'est celle de la dégustation
la finale opposait claude à jessica
dites nous si vous pouvez le faire vous
l'épreuve de négation je sais que jean
mi ça ne dérange pas trop su si toi tu
peux sauf l'oeil de poisson
alors regardez
dégustation bien particulière un oeil de
barracuda vert de cocotiers et un
coquillage plus en tous cas c'est saint
claude oh là là je veux toucher à rien
c'est quoi ce délire bouge pas trop le
temps ne tient bouge pas c'est parti
jessica a choisi le coquillage cru qui
est le plus gros
j'ai failli me sens bien c'est déjà bien
bien que lundi
ok vas-y des travaux
avaler cavale
la victoire pour que ces énormes avale
avale et ça c'est vraiment l'épreuve
pour moi la pile de 90 à ce service
franchement je pense que je passerai mon
tour là dessus je pense que voilà je
perdrais direct oui sophie koch non mais
je suis assez d'accord avec nous puis je
vois pas très bien l'intérêt en fait à
part je trouve ça juste dégoûtant mais
je vois pas le le courage maintenant
assis dans la si on assure vie on a tout
dit on sait pourquoi manger on va devoir
manger vous trouve dans la nature est
quelque chose que vous ne savez pas sur
moi si je sais que quand j'étais plus
jeune c'était instructrice de tir à la
non et les séries je suis fan de tir à
l'arc bas donc j'aimerais bien vous
proposer un duel canton ça avec plaisir
avec grange et c'est pas mon chéri grand
plaisir savais que j'étais chez tg au
tir à l'arc ouest
j'ai tout fait j'ai fait tir à l'arc
fléchettes j'ai fait chef des sports
j'ai fait j'ai fait ce fait défaut ce
faire le chef des sports terrestres chef
des sports aquatiques
voilà vous faisait chaque signe dans
l'eau non mais voilà